I'm in conversation with this wonderful
retired Air Force Major David antoon has
really put himself and his family on the
line to speak up against the
evangelisation of the military Michael
Ratner is the head of the Center for
Constitutional Rights and I adore that
whole organization I have like a crush
on the whole organization I'm I like
threw a party for their interns because
I just wanted to do something you know
to show my love they took on defending
the detainees out of respect for the
rule of law when absolutely no one would
touch that and that's what John Adams
did he put his career on the line to
defend the most hated prisoners of the
time soldiers charged with the Boston
Massacre because of his respect for the
rule of law so Michael Ratner is a real
hero and the whole CC are our heroes and
Marjorie Cohn of the National Lawyers
Guild I really admire I was just on the
phone as I mentioned with Charlotte
Dennett who's saying in public that
she's going to arrest the President or
prosecute the president rather if she's
elected and I think that's gutsy you
know I met these wonderful young Vietnam
I'm sorry he's wonderful young Iran I
met these wonderful young Iraq vets who
had the courage and patriotism to take
their protest about Veterans Affairs to
the gates of the debate and you know
were trampled by police you know as a
consequence and there they were the next
night you know at my event standing up
and saying it again I mean that's those
are American heroes you know they are
not being silenced oh so many Josh wolf
no relation he's he's in the book he's a
blogger in San Francisco who spent seven
months in federal prison because he
wouldn't hand over his horses to federal
investigators material he had about a
protest seven months because he believed
in his job as a journalist i have to say
i wish i had more heroes in the national
media right now but there are many many
brave Americans many brave Americans I'm
meeting across the country you know well
well known but many who are not well
known
who are really you know history's going
to look back and say those are the
heroes